this is a truly special turning point is
a testament to the incredible support
from so many alumni in France is an
occasion about R attitude and
celebration welcome to this event
commemorating the dedication
of the knight Management Center I feel
like I will be there oh this is amazing
it's a wonderful new beginning for the
business school the facility is
everything we dreamed on you know you're
planted on paper and then you watch
people discover it when I was here I
thought that Stanford was the best place
on earth and this is even better a great
day for skipper
all of us who live here and work here
and teach you or just blown away the
thought that went into it the energy
that comes out of it
I just think about 30 years ago and it
was great the experience but this is
going to set the stage for the next 50
years we've never left this sense of
potential you get definitely proud of
being the IGS BLM I just love the
community feel and the openness to the
University Stanford Business School
really stands for the entrepreneurship
innovation and change that's what the
knight Management Center brilliantly
showcases friendship in the community
developed here during your time at
school is just a singular experience
that we'll never forget
great thing about the GSB is that our
alumni state ride to the school and this
is a better time than ever to renew that
collaboration in that time
we moved out to Boston most weekends
we're hanging out with someone either
from my class or my wife's class I found
the people that I was with here the kind
of people that I want to have my life
for the rest of my life there's such an
intimate experience for students at the
GSB and that continues lifelong for the
Alumni to mentor the first thing we do
is a good shield what are we going to
make happen how do we make things better
it's very infectious
I've mixed several islands that have
inspired me but professionally and
personally GSB alum and provided me with
opportunities that I otherwise wouldn't
have and wouldn't have been able to find
anywhere else great role models they've
been great friends and they've been
great out points inspiration what three
words define and drive you there are
nearly 600 flags with amazing messages
flying around the square my experience
at the GSB really set the stage to not
be intimidated by anything if you work
hard and you're smart anything can
happen to lifelong experience it's not
one you just come and do two years and
leave it's about change and changing the
world to come back
single word uplifting it's great to see
the bright young kids and that's our
future it boys me the school will define
the word management for future
generations the school will change the
world
just come back and see what it's like
see what our students are doing feel the
energy give yourself back to that
community that can learn so much from
you